and now for tonight's speaker Jason
Riley is a senior fellow at the
Manhattan Institute and a columnist for
The Wall Street Journal where he has
worked for more than 20 years writing
opinion pieces on politics economics
education government race and many other
subjects he's also a commentator for Fox
News where he has appeared for more than
a decade and a frequent public speaker
after joining the journal in 1994 he was
named a senior editorial page writer in
2000 and a member of the editorial board
in 2005 in 2008 he published let the men
which argues for a more free market
oriented u.s. immigration policy his
second book please stop helping us was
published in 2014 born in Buffalo New
York mr. Riley earned a bachelor's
degree in English from the State
University of New York at Buffalo
he lives in suburban New York City with
his wife and three children would you
please welcome Jason Riley
thank you for that for that introduction
and thank you for the invitation to
speak here this evening I make it a
habit of accepting any invitation to
speak from a red state it is it's my fan
base basically I spend most of my time
in two of the bluest cities in the
country New York and Washington where
almost no one reads The Wall Street
Journal editorial page or watches Fox
News so when I'm recognized it's usually
by someone hostile who's chasing me down
the street
something to that effect of course those
two cities have basically repealed the
Second Amendment so I can't even defend
myself but boy you know when I fly in a
Dallas I can't get out of the terminal
without people recognizing me you put me
in a hotel lobby in Memphis and I'll
have total strangers yelling at me keep
giving them hell Riley it's just it's
it's it's awesome so so thank you thank
you so much for getting me out of blue
America for for a few days I really
appreciate it but I want to thank
Hillsdale and the end the Durrell
Foundation for having me here today
as as anita mentioned my first book was
about immigration my second book was
about race so obviously I picked the
easy topics the ones that bring us
together as a country and make me very
popular on social media and cable news
but actually tonight I I wanted to talk
about something that I think most people
do agree on which is that despite a
half-century of concerted efforts by
civil rights leaders and politicians the
black underclass is in pretty
and what we're trying is not working
very well
now the agreement pretty much ends there
but it is a start so let's begin with
with the good news this year marks the
50th anniversary of what may be martin
luther king's most significant
achievement the Voting Rights Act of
1965 now last year we celebrated the
fiftieth anniversary of the Civil Rights
Act of 1964 which of course outlawed
discrimination based on race gender
religion and gave blacks access to jobs
and schools and public facilities that
had previously been denied to them but
access to the voting booth access to the
ballot was still a challenge for blacks
particularly in the south President
Lincoln said we're government of the
people by the people for the people but
that's only true if all the people can
register and vote the ability to vote is
what protects all the other freedoms we
enjoy in this country it's how we hold
our elected officials accountable for
the decisions they make so after the
Civil Rights Act was passed dr. King
pressed for a Voting Rights Act two and
fifty years ago this summer President
Johnson signed it into law and it's been
a remarkable success just to give you a
sense of how successful the Voting
Rights Act it's has been in 1964 the
year before it passed only 7% of blacks
in the state of Mississippi were
registered to vote lowest percentage in
the south
by 1966 just one year after the Voting
Rights Act passed black voter
registration in Mississippi had climbed
to 60% the highest in the south and
Mississippi wasn't alone in Georgia it
went from 19% to 51% in fact in every
southern state the gains were striking
today black voter registration in the
South were most blacks to live is higher
than it is in other parts of the country
and in 2012 the last presidential
election the percentage of blacks who
voted was higher the percentage of
whites who voted and for the first time
in US history
that's how significant the Voting Rights
Act has been along with the Civil Rights
Act it's represented the culmination of
a modern-day civil rights movement and
what I wanted to talk about for a few
minutes this evening is what has
happened in the wake of these civil
rights victories and political victories
that were supposed to lead to greater
economic prosperity particularly for the
black poor what is risen from the ruins
of Jim Crow terms of policies aimed at
blacks in general and the black
underclass in particular where has there
been progress where has there been
retrogression what's working what's not
working and how much of what's not
working can we blame on racism I think
it's a good time to ask those questions
because this year also marks the 50th
anniversary of the Great Society
programs that were supposed to eliminate
poverty and reduce racial inequality in
America just before assigning that
Voting Rights Act into law Lyndon
Johnson gave a famous speech at Howard
University the historically black
college in Washington DC where he talked
about what the government should do next
on behalf of blacks this was merely the
end of the beginning he said and then he
said that beginning is freedom and the
barriers to that freedom are tumbling
down
freedom is the right to share share
fully and equally in American society to
vote to hold a job in our public place
to go to school said Johnson but freedom
is not enough he added you do not take a
person who for years has been hobbled by
chains and liberate him bring him up to
the starting line of a race and then say
you are free to compete with all the
others and think that you have been
completely fair to that person Johnson
said that the next and more profound
stage of the battle for civil rights was
not just equality as a right and a
theory but equality as a fact and
equality as a result Johnson had moved
the goalposts he was saying that equal
opportunity isn't enough he wanted the
government to ensure equal outcomes but
what if Johnson was mistaken what if
there are limits to what the government
can do beyond removing barriers to
freedom what if the best that we can
hope for from our elected officials or
policies that promote a level playing
field and what if policy makers risk
creating more problems to progress more
barriers to progress when the focus is
on equal outcomes I think there are
limits even when the policies are well
intentioned and I think the past
half-century is evidence of that for
more than 50 years the political left
has pushed for more government
assistance for blacks the racial
preferences forced integration expanded
welfare entitlements and so forth black
leaders have urged racial solidarity and
prioritized the pursuit of political
power between 1970 and 2010 the number
of black elected officials in America
grew from fewer than 1500 to more than
10,000
including of course a black president
but how has this helped the black
underclass in 2013 Mississippi had more
black elected officials than any other
state in the nation yet it continues to
have one of the highest poverty rates in
the nation including black poverty over
the past half century the US has spent
some 20 trillion dollars after inflation
on anti-poverty programs alone what do
we have to show for it
the official poverty rate in 2012 was
higher than it was in 1966 and the
black-white poverty gap has widened over
the past decade the racial disparity and
incarceration rates is also larger today
than it was in 1960 black unemployment
on average has been twice as high as
white unemployment for five decades yes
gains have been made on balanced blacks
are certainly better off than they were
in 1965 but the track record regarding
the black poor is appalling
it's clear that government programs
aren't the solution to many of the
problems this group faces the Great
Society programs may be well intentioned
but they aren't getting the job done and
the question is why the short answer is
that the focus has been on
redistributing wealth to blacks instead
of producing wealth among blacks the
lesson of the past 50 years ought to be
that simply transferring cash and
in-kind benefits and services to the
poor does not necessarily make people
more prosperous
I think blacks ultimately must help
themselves they must evolve the same
attitudes and habits and behaviors that
other groups developed
in order to rise in America and to the
extent that a government policy however
well-intentioned interferes with that
necessary self development it's doing
more harm than good
open-ended welfare benefits do not help
people develop a work ethic which is
ultimately what they must develop in
order to rise out of poverty increasing
the minimum wage to whatever the number
is today $15 an hour will simply
increase the cost of hiring younger or
less experienced workers many of whom
happen to be black so fewer blacks will
wind up getting that first job and the
experience that comes with it soft on
crime policies make ghettos more
dangerous for the mostly law-abiding
residents who live there and they make
life easier for the criminals who of
course prey primarily on the black poor
and so on yet all of these policies
continue to be pushed in the name of
helping the black poor and the promoters
of the policies don't seem very
interested in reevaluating what has been
tried before it's also important to note
the progress that was occurring among
blacks prior to the implementation of
these policies that have been designed
to help them programs that often receive
all of the credit for any progress that
we have seen for example between 1940
and 1960 black poverty in the u.s. fell
by 40 percentage points that's before
the Civil Rights Act and the Voting
Rights Acts were passed that was during
Jim Crow that was during a period of
open rampant and legal discrimination in
this country racial discrimination a 40
percentage point drop in black poverty
now poverty continued to fall after the
Great Society programs were implemented
in the 1960s but at a much slower rate
at best the great society continued a
trend already in place yet these
programs are given all the credit for
any reductions in poverty that we've
seen the reality is that no Great
Society program has ever come close to
matching the reduction in black poverty
that we saw prior to the implementation
of that policy no Great Society program
has ever come close to matching what
blacks were doing on their own before
the government decided to step in and
help the notion that black people has
helped themselves is not based on some
right-wing extremist ideology it's based
on experience history shows that there
simply is no substitute for a groups
self-development
government programs cannot save us and
an over-dependence on them can do great
harm affirmative action racial
preferences are another example of a
program that gets more credit than it
deserves in this case credit for
increasing the size of the black middle
class again what does the record show
well it shows that between 1930 and 1970
the percentage of black white collar
workers quadrupled in the u.s. between
1950 and 1960 in New York City alone the
number of black accountants increased by
220 percent the number of engineers grew
by one hundred and thirty-four percent
the number of teachers grew by one
hundred and twenty five percent
physicians and lawyers grew by 56
percent and 55 percent respectively
nurses increased by 90 percent and so on
that's before affirmative action
policies were implemented that's during
a period when you could put a sign in
your window that said we don't hire
blacks yet in the face of these
obstacles blacks were entering the
skilled professions at unprecedented
rates
again yes blacks continued to enter the
white-collar professions in the wake of
racial preferences but again that simply
continued an existing trend there was a
substantial black middle-class already
in existence by the end of the 1960s it
has continued to grow but at a much
slower rate and as with black poverty
reduction no affirmative action program
has ever come close to matching what
blacks were doing on their own prior to
the implementation of the policy
moreover racial preferences have not
helped the poor as the proponents
promised instead they have worked mostly
to help already well-off blacks become
better off there have been case studies
for example in Atlanta in the 1970s and
80s were under black mayors like Maynard
Jackson and Andrew Young the city
implemented racial preference policies
for hiring black city workers and black
contractors well what happened while the
number of successful black businesses
increased rapidly but average income
blacks were left behind and the black
poor actually lost ground and that's
been the story of the black poor not
only in Atlanta of a nationwide in the
era of affirmative action the black
underclass has lost ground both in
absolute terms and relative to the white
underclass in the 1970s and 80s and even
into the 1990s so we're talking about
the first full decades of affirmative
action policies the poorest 20 percent
of blacks saw their incomes decline at
more than double the rate of comparable
White's again the empirical data shows
that in an era of racial preferences and
quotas and set asides put in place to
help the
lack poor that subset has regressed
affirmative action in higher education
was also supposed to increase the ranks
of black professionals but after
California banned racial preferences and
college admissions what happened well
black graduation rates rose instead of
being funneled into schools where they
admit it were they were overmatched but
admitted anyway for diversity reasons
black students started going or started
doing with white students and Asian
students already do they attended
schools that better matched their skill
level and as a result more of them
graduated a lot more black graduation
rates of the University of California
system increased by more than 50%
after racial preferences were ended
including in the more difficult fields
of math and science and engineering by
more than 50%
in other words racial preferences which
were sold as a way to increase the size
of the black middle class had resulted
in fewer black doctors fewer black
lawyers and architects and engineers and
physicists than we would have had in the
absence of these policies but I would
also argue that there is a large
cultural component to the racial
disparities that we see today whether
we're talking about employment education
incarceration incomes or other measures
yeah that's become almost taboo to talk
about black cultural problems in America
antisocial behavior attitudes towards
work school parenting and so forth black
kids teasing one another for acting
white I've often told the story about a
trip back home to Buffalo New York where
I was born and raised I was visiting my
older sister shortly after I'd begun
work
at The Wall Street Journal and I was
chatting with her daughter my niece who
was maybe in the second grade at the
time was asking her about school their
favorite subjects that sort of thing
when she stopped me
she said Uncle Jason why you talk white
when she turned to her little friend who
was sitting there beside her and said
don't my uncle sound white why are you
trying to sound so smart now she was
just teasing of course and I smiled and
they enjoyed a little chuckle at my
expense but what she said really stayed
with me I couldn't help thinking here
were two young black girls seven or
eight years old already
linking speech patterns to intelligence
and race
even at that young age they already had
a rather sophisticated awareness that as
blacks white sounding speech was not
only to be avoided in their own speech
but mocked in the speech of other blacks
and I shouldn't have been too surprised
by this and I wasn't my siblings along
with countless other black friends and
relatives teased me the same way when I
was growing up and other black
professionals from the president and the
first lady on down told similar stories
what I had forgotten is just how early
these attitudes take hold how soon this
counterproductive thinking and behavior
begins New York City where I'm based has
the largest school system in America and
80% of black kids in public schools are
performing below grade level 80 percent
and a big part of the problem is a black
subculture that rejects attitudes and
behavior is conducive to academic
success black kids read half as many
books and watch twice as much television
as their white and Asian counterparts
for example in other words a big part of
the problem is a culture that produces
little black girls who are already
worried about acting and sounding white
by the time they are in second grade
another big part of the problem is a
reluctance to speak honestly about these
cultural shortcomings many whites feel
being called racist and many black
leaders have a vested interest in
blaming black problems primarily on
white racism so that is the narrative
they push regardless of the reality
racism has become an all-purpose
explanation for bad black outcome
be they social or economic if you
disagree in our white you're a bigot if
you disagree in our black you're a
sellout too often this is the level of
discourse schoolyard name-calling even
President Obama has been subjected to
this treatment when he's broached the
topic of black cultural shortcomings on
several occasions he's spoken to black
audiences about for example absent black
fathers when he spoke at Morehouse black
college in Atlanta a couple years ago he
said quote I was raised by a heroic
single mother and wonderful grandparents
who made incredible sacrifices for me
but I still wish I had a father who was
not only present but involved and so my
whole life I've tried to be for Michelle
and my girls what my father wasn't for
my mother and me I've tried to be a
better father a better husband a better
man Obama told those black men in the
audience to be good role models for
other less fortunate black men he said
the brothers who have been left behind
who haven't had the same opportunities
we have they need to hear from us we
need to be in the barbershops with them
at church with them helping to pull them
up exposing them to new opportunities we
have to teach them what it means to be a
man now that might sound like common
sense to you and me and there are
probably some people in this room who
wish this is all Obama would ever talk
about
but Obama gets slammed by liberals in
general and black liberals in particular
when he says these sorts of things
because he's seen as criticizing black
culture condescending the blacks being
an elitist most significantly
he's accused of letting whites off the
hook which is a big no-no on the black
left you don't do that
but the facts are on Obama's side for
decades studies have shown that the
likelihood of teen pregnancy drug abuse
dropping out of school and many other
bad social outcomes increased
dramatically when fathers aren't around
one of the most comprehensive studies
ever done about this concluded that
black boys without a father were 68
percent more likely to be incarcerated
as those with the father the study said
that overall the most critical factor
affecting the prospect that a male youth
will encounter the criminal justice
system is the presence of a father in
the home all other factors including
family income are much less important
one social scientists put it this way if
crime is to a significant degree caused
by weak character if we character is
more likely among children of unmarried
mothers
if there are no fathers who will help
raise their children acquire jobs
protect their neighborhoods if boys
become young men with no preparation for
work if school achievement is regarded
as a sign of having sold out if all
these things are true then the chances
of reducing the crime rate among
low-income blacks anytime soon is slim
this is what we see playing out in
Baltimore and the Bronx st. Louis
Chicago in Detroit but you're not
supposed to say that it's politically
incorrect to say that try to bring up
black culture in a debate over criminal
behavior today you will have your head
handed to you try to bring up the
breakdown of the black family in a
debate about crime in fact we don't even
talk about black crime anymore we talk
about black incarceration rates is that
the two are completely unrelated we talk
about police shootings of black men as a
measure of whether America values black
lives or whether cops value black lives
we have mobs of people all over this
country pretending that there's an
epidemic of cops shooting blacks and the
media has played right along this is
nonsense police are involved in
approximately 2% a black shooting deaths
each year one economist has calculated
that a cop is about six times as likely
to be shot by someone black as the
opposite scenario blacks are about 13%
of the US population but commit more
than half of all murders in the country
roughly 7,000 blacks are murdered each
year and 90 percent of them are killed
by other blacks the question isn't
whether cops value black lives or
whether America values black lives isn't
the more relevant question whether the
young black men doing all of this
killing value black lives are we
supposed to hold White's to a higher
standard than blacks hold each other I
think a previous generation the civil
rights leaders would have laughed at
that notion
homicide is the leezak leading cause of
death for young black men in the US and
it's not because cops are shooting them
bad cops should be punished to the full
extent of the law and they should
certainly be held to a high standard for
violating the public trust but if you
believe that black lives matter if you
want to reduce that black body count as
a practical matter should your focus be
on the 2 percent of black shooting
deaths that involve cops or the 98
percent that don't the violence that is
so prevalent in these neighborhoods in
these black ghettos has enormous
economic consequences the common
assumption is that poverty causes crime
but the truth is closer to the reverse
businesses flee crime-ridden
neighborhoods jobs follow property
values fall one reason that blacks were
progressing at a much faster rate in the
first half of the 20th century is that
black communities were much less violent
back then the violence so prevalent
today dates to the policy interventions
of the 1960s when coddling criminals
became fashionable among judges and
among politicians and yes among
academics and the government mistakenly
believed that a welfare check could
replace a father in the home before 1960
two out of three black children were
raised in two-parent families two-thirds
today more than seventy percent or not
and in some of our inner cities many of
our inner cities it's as high as 80 or
90 percent before 1960 homicide rates in
the u.s. in
including among blacks had been falling
significantly in fact the murder rate in
1960 was less than half of what it had
been 25 years earlier blacks obviously
faced much more racism back then but
black communities were also much safer
and therefore much more conducive to
social and economic progress which is
what we saw let me close by noting that
this concept of self help and self
development that I think is essential to
black advancement is something that
black leaders in this country once
understood very well and at a time when
blacks faced infinitely more racial
barriers than they faced with a twice
elected black man in the Oval Office
Frederick Douglass a former slave said
in 1865 that everybody had asked him and
the other abolitionists what to do with
the Negro he said I've had but one
answer from the beginning do nothing
with us if the apples will not remain on
the tree of their own strength let them
fall and if the Negro cannot stand on
his own legs let him fall also all I ask
is give him a chance to stand on his own
two legs Douglass was essentially saying
give blacks equal opportunity and then
leave us alone Booker T Washington
another former slave echoed that
sentiment he said that it is important
and right that all the privileges of the
law be ours but it is vastly more
important that we be prepared for the
exercise of these privileges Douglass
and Washington did not play down the
need for the government to secure equal
rights for blacks and both were
optimistic that they would one day
receive equal rights although neither
man lived to see that day
but both men also understood the limits
of government benevolence they
understood that blacks would have to
ready themselves to meet the far bigger
challenge of being in a position to take
advantage of opportunities once equal
rights had been secured I think the
history of the 1960's liberal social
programs is largely a history of
ignoring that wisdom the Obama
presidency is yet more evidence that
blacks have progressed politically in
this country but if the rise of other
racial and ethnic groups is any
indication black social and economic
problems are less about politics than
about culture a black man in the White
House is all well and good but it is no
substitute for a black man in the home
on that happy note I will end and take
any questions
there Paul Raven Hillsdale College hi
I spent the summer of 1966 in Chicago
I heard Martin Luther King speak a
little Lutheran Church shook his hand
but that summer I also met the
leadership of Blackstone Rangers and I
had the impression that they were being
funded by the poverty program of Lyndon
Baines Johnson and that attempt was
being made to overthrow the existing
african-american leadership within the
black community and replace it with a
new leadership
am I right about that and has that had
an impact
I couldn't possibly speak to that I was
born in 1971 so I I really can't speak
to that but maybe maybe someone else
here that yes does church attendance
make a difference I think potentially
yes
I mean I've spoken to groups of black
member of black ministers and they
certainly embrace this message of self
help and self development and not blame
you at all
on white racism one of the problems is
that their pews are all full of women
when in this messages really needs to
get to black men and while the church is
still a very respected institution in in
the black community one of the few left
attendance is an issue but yes I think
that it still can and does play an
important role
and what I'm talking about yes oh okay
mr. Riley mr. Riley
you mentioned the breakdown in the
family as a major cause of poverty in
other areas and of course this is not
just constrained to black families it's
also white families and we tend to think
what can the government do to reduce
this breakdown but what can we as a
society do to reduce the breakdown of
the family and to strengthen families I
don't have the answers I don't pretend
to have the answers but I do think that
I can play a useful role and talking
about and writing about the past what
has been tried before what has worked
and then the people that do profess to
have the answers hopefully will be
informed by this track record of success
and failure as it may be I think one
thing we can do is to have honest
conversations about the problem which we
don't have in this country we talked
about tensions between police and the
black community and how to solve these
tensions without talking about black
crime rates we talk about blacks not
trusting cops and so you're getting
situations like Ferguson or Baltimore
black people call the cops more than
anyone in America that's a funny way of
showing you don't trust the police the
tensions between the police and the
black community stem from high black
crime rates the police are in these
communities because of that is with a
911 calls originated
if you want to reduce tensions between
the police and these communities you
need to reduce crime in these
communities if you want to deal with
this perception of young black men as
being menacing you need to deal with the
behavior that is driving those
perceptions it's not coming out of
nowhere and it's not limited to whites
perceiving young black men as menacing
other blacks have the same problem so
again we need to have honest
conversations about the problem I think
we have to start there and if we're not
going to talk about black crime rates if
we're not going to talk about black
behavior aren't we're simply not having
an honest conversation I'm the president
founder of homemakers America so my
whole thing is always you know we need
to help the moms realize how important
they are in homes the communities but
things that you have said tonight have
been very enlightening that if all the
moms are filling the churches and the
men still aren't there there's a law
here in Nebraska the community learning
community and it is a tax that was
supposed to help the people in the
lower-income communities particularly in
North Omaha and I drove kids from North
Omaha down to Papillion schools for four
months last year and I don't understand
what this culture thing is if they care
about education so much that they want
to take their children from the black
community and bring them down into
communities with our white kids or they
think they're going to get a better
education two things with this aside
from the tax issue they're going from
their community down here to get the
better edge
education but they're going back home to
the completely dysfunctional homes where
they're getting most of their
understanding of the world there is a
major disconnect there and what I would
like to know is how do we heal that
disconnect obviously the tax isn't
working
throwing the money at it isn't working
but how do we help them with that
disconnect if the culture is don't be
intelligent but yet they want their
children to come to better schools how
do we connect the dots not just heal the
family but help them see that their
children are getting there their
greatest influence in that home and if
they want to have a better education why
are they then counteracting it when they
come home well I think this is an
example of a disconnect that's been in
place for a while between the black
leadership and the the needs and desires
of rank-and-file blacks and and this is
you can some people in this room are old
enough to remember the 1970s and the
busing wars that we had where the
n-double-a-cp types wanted kids put on
buses and and and bussed an hour away to
school every day rank-and-file blacks
never wanted that they wanted good
schools belt right there in the
community the n-double-a-cp
wanted that of course their kids weren't
on those buses but but that's so there
has long been a disconnect between the
agenda of the civil rights industry as I
refer to it today and what rank-and-file
blacks have wanted and access to better
schools is as a perfect example of that
I was speaking to someone earlier
tonight about this you know for many on
the Left public education is first and
foremost a jobs program for adults the
kids are a secondary concern so failing
school stay open even if they're not
graduating anyone because they're still
providing jobs so school choice is one
way to get at this problem to give these
parents access to better schools and I
think that's where you start with a
better education and you build a natural
constituency of
who are better informed about their
needs and how to go about pursuing those
needs for the next generation but you
have a lot of kids trapped in failing
schools and they're desperate to get out
and a lot of the policies we have in
place won't let them out and it's it's
really shameful even you know with this
administration blocking school voucher
programs in places not only in his
backyard in Washington DC but in states
like Louisiana where the governor there
signed a statewide voucher program
Justice Department has come in and said
it violates desegregation orders without
are on the books from the 1970s so we
can't pass this um we can't let this
about your program proceed it'll upset
the racial balance of schools the racial
makeup of the school is more important
than whether anyone is learning in the
school this is nonsense black kids need
quality schools more than they need
white classmates I promise you that so
if some of the best schools in the state
of New York where I am and in the
country are highly segregated because
these charter schools these high
performing charter schools go in to
these desperate communities and set up
shop and those communities are
segregated so the schools and they're
being segregated that is not my concern
the concerns whether the schools work or
not whether they're graduating kids
whether they're sending them to college
whether the kids are learning in a safe
environment this administration has has
this anti-bullying initiative it is
pressuring local school districts to
suspend kids not based on who is doing
the bullying but to make sure there is
racial parity in suspension rates how do
you help the black kid who was in school
to learn by not suspending the bullies
how is this helpful
and by the way why would you expect to
find racial parity
and disciplinary outcomes in school do
you find them outside of school do you
think this behavior just starts after
they graduate
so the whole premise is off but so as
are the priorities and so are who I
think the policymakers should be
sympathized with Obama's gonna release
some 6,000 federal inmates because he
thinks they were sentenced too harshly
in the 80s and 90s he promises us that
they are nonviolent we have a very very
poor track record of deciding who was
going to turn a new leaf when they get
out a very poor track record in this
country back in 2002 the Justice
Department put out a study of 91
thousand people released in 15 states
supposedly non-violent more than 20%
were really three years for violent
offenses including more than 700 murders
in more than six hundred rapes
Philadelphia tried this as well we need
to reduce overcrowding in our prisons
will reduce what will send will let the
non violent criminals go it didn't work
out similar outcomes so we just do a
very poor job of determining who's gonna
be nonviolent but my bigger point is
where are our sympathies why are they
with the criminals instead of their
victims when these guys get out they are
headed back to the hood they are headed
right back to these communities where
they were raising hell in the first
place Hillary Clinton can go out and
complain about mass incarceration all
she wants
Hillary Clinton lives in a suburb of New
York not far from where I live
multi-million dollar homes when these
guys get out they are not headed to
Hillary Clinton's neighborhood they are
headed back to the South Bronx they are
headed back to Harlem they are headed
back to the southside of Chicago
they will not be her problem
how are you helping the law-abiding
residents of these communities by going
soft on crime you are not and that's you
know that's part of my problem with the
priorities of some of these policymakers
mr. Ali I'm Howard Baker from Baltimore
I admire your work so and I've been
eager to ask you this question since I
knew I'd be here tonight with you and I
imagine we're gonna disagree but I'm
eager to hear what you have to say with
respect to crime it seems that it seemed
to me for a long time that one of the
most important things we can do for a
low-income areas generally a special
especially black low-income areas is to
repeal prohibition I'm talking about
repealing I'm talking about the
prohibition of drugs because that drug
war creates a tremendous amount of crime
those who have disagreements can't go to
the courts so they use violence I'm very
interested to hear your opinion on that
because it seemed to me a long time that
it's one of the very most important
policies policy changes we should have
just for the purpose of reducing crime I
think this is a red herring the drug
offenses are not what is driving the
incarceration rate in America violent
offenses drive the incarceration rate in
America if you could let me back up a
little bit
most inmates are housed in state local
prisons not the federal prison system so
I'll use speakers regarding the state
and local prison system which houses
around 90 percent of all inmates in the
country if you could snap your fingers
and send home
everyone locked up for a drug offense
you would not appreciably change the
percentage of blacks behind bars blacks
are about 30 minutes in the population
they're about 37 percent of the inmates
again you could send home everyone in
prison black and white who was there for
a drug offense blacks would still be
right about 37% of the inmate population
it is violent offenses that are driving
the incarceration rate in this country
by far it's not even close this idea
that we are locking up young black kids
caught with a joint is not true there is
no room for these folks you are not
going to prison or jail if you get
caught with a dime bag by a cop that is
a myth
it's simply not true so I can be
agnostic on the drug war whether it
should be legal or illegal it can be
completely agnostic I think there are a
lot of good arguments for ending the
drug war and and and and legalizing
recreational use of some of these
substances but the idea that you are
going to appreciably affect the
percentage of blacks locked up I think
is completely off-base because it is not
drug offenses that's driving the
incarceration right this will be our
final question Dan Stacy and Jackson
County Republican Committee down in
Kansas City I wonder certainly I think
many of us resonate with what you're
saying tonight and would like to move
this this ball forward however you can
say these things with some degree of
acceptance simply because of your color
some of us don't have that opportunity
or don't share that same opportunity how
can all of us move this ball forward and
not be part of the problem but share
truth well I I it's not your fight
that's that's really what it comes down
to I think that blacks ultimately have
to
themselves these calls for a national
conversation are silly I mean you can
all join in the conversation I welcome
your input but ultimately blacks have to
figure this out for themselves the
conversation has to be had with these
young black kids in Chicago shooting
each other and who who have no role
models who have no no sense of what it
means to be a man or what it means to be
black for that matter and they're gonna
need an authority figure in their lives
and typically traditionally historically
that has been a father and maybe a
minister can fill that role maybe a
teacher can fill that role but
ultimately this is something the black
community is gonna have to work out on
its own and it's not about reinventing
the wheel here it's about getting back
to a time period when we did not have
these levels of violence in the black
community and I think I'm optimistic
that that can happen but it's hard for
it to happen when you're letting people
out of prison early and sending them
back to the community sooner rather than
later to raise hell it's hard for it to
happen when you have a false narrative
out there about cops shooting black men
left and right for no reason at all it's
hard for that to happen when everyone
from a President United States on down
is indulging this black lives matter
movement nonsense so yeah there are from
a public policy perspective and this
goes to the title of my last book please
stop helping us I think there are things
that the the government can do and the
policymakers can do from the standpoint
of simply no longer doing things we know
don't work stop raising the minimum wage
that prices these young kids out of the
labor force you know stop trapping them
in failing schools stop with the
occupational licensing requirements that
prevent them from star
a business a hair braiding salon a cab
service or so forth government can get
out of the way but I don't think the
solutions are necessarily going to come
from Washington or from politicians
other groups traditionally have not gone
this route the civil rights movement
made a decision back in the 60s to
pursue political power over economic
power they were not the only group to go
this route but this is the route they
chose and traditionally and historically
both in the US and outside of the u.s.
that is a route to slower progress most
other groups have not gone that route
politics political power has come later
if at all
the Irish are an example of a group that
chose the same route as the blacks if
you go back to the 1920s you had Irish
political machines running major cities
in the United States from Boston to
Philadelphia to New York but the Irish
underclass was struggling
the Irish masses were struggling and in
fact it wasn't until the decline of
those Irish political machines that you
saw average rises in Irish incomes in
America the politics did not bring along
the masses and the blacks have chosen
that route it's a much slower route most
other groups have not worried about
elected officials not worried about
group leaders speaking on their behalf
and and and and participating or
creating some sort of racial or ethnic
spoils system to bring goodies back home
to the community that has not been the
focus they focused on intact families
and educational achievement and so forth
look out if you look at America today
and which group is hitting it out of the
park in terms of incomes in terms of
educational attainment Asians how much
political clout do Asians have in
America it's just traditionally not been
the route that most successful groups
have made trying to rise from poverty to
prosperity
so so I don't think these solutions are
going to come from Washington ultimately
this is about the black community
getting its act together and that will
start with an honest conversation about
the problem which i think is not white
racism it's about black culture and
attitudes and behaviors being conducive
to socio-economic success and that's
frankly not a conversation that the
civil rights community wants to have
because if it's not about white racism
anymore
al Sharpton and Jesse Jackson are
irrelevant and they can't let that
happen
so they are going to keep white racism
front and center in our national
conversation because they need to stay
relevant and that's that's the problem
we have and of course the media
continues to run to those guys to speak
on behalf of black America so it's hard
to start the right conversation